[Music]
what's up buddy man it's good to see you
yes for early in the trip yeah for be
thinking it happens we talked about for
quite some time I know so you first came
on to my radar via John Joseph or Paul
he's a badass get him on the show he
didn't say just that knowing John yeah
sixteen more sentences yeah we're taking
your breath yeah yeah yes I start
following you on Instagram and I was
like wow this guy's inspiring that's
doing some cool stuff and then we just
bumped into each other up at Point Dume
now here we are man yeah man worked out
it was nice baby yeah I'm excited to
share your story you're definitely an
inspiring cat and what you've overcome
is just mind-blowing and the extent to
which you extend yourself in service of
others and in an environmental context
is really impressive and like I said
inspiring the funny thing is none of
that feels true does it feel like
yes feels like like I'm just living life
yeah it's weed and this story has now
kind of just lost it's not like it lost
meaning it just really to me never felt
like it had a huge meaning everyone says
oh my god you know that must have been
horrible I was like yeah it's you know
it's a bad day at work and that's really
all it was and I maybe that's testament
to why I don't have any PTSD or I don't
have any nightmares no flashbacks I've
never had counseling that's not I think
I'm pretty normal except for the things
that I do for my job they're not normal
do you find that when you get up you do
a lot of talk to get up in front of
people all the time and share your story
do you have that weird experience of
kind of being disassociated from your
own story because you've told it so many
times you like my is this actually
happen editorial eyes especially when
you're doing it a lot so I did a company
where they wanted me to hit every shift
and I had to do it 16 no 18 times in six
days you say three times a day four
and by the second day I hated the sound
of my own voice I I didn't know which
part of the story I was up to I was
thinking to myself have I already told
this part I can't remember I've said it
so many times by the 18th day I just I
couldn't do it anymore I wrote a whole
month off uh-huh and just didn't talk
about myself at all one of the things
that I found though is that when I get
up and tell it it starts to tell me more
about the story like I learned more
about myself because I realize like oh
that happened because of it like I make
these weird connections ya idly wasn't
really kind of consciously aware of and
things that you might have forgotten
about that you have been retelling the
story for a certain amount of time and
then all of a sudden 20 times you've
been onstage and all of a sudden the
twenty first time you'll be telling this
story and you'll think oh [ __ ] well
actually this happened as well and I
totally forgot about that so there's
elements over the years that have added
themselves and made the story even more
powerful especially to me because it
makes it more interesting when I
remember things I've forgotten or I
talked to someone that was there that
day and they remind me of something I
forgot right sticking one of the guys
having to stick his hand inside my leg
and pinch closed an artery
so that I wouldn't die mm-hmm it's crazy
stuff it's crazy well rather than just
kind of launch into the the day that
kind of catalyzed all of this I'd like
to go back to the beginning because this
is very much like like a hero's journey
you know I mean I think in in order to
kind of really fully appreciate and
understand like where are you where you
are now and and what you had to overcome
like I think it's important to
understand your upbringing in your
childhood because that in and of itself
is an amazing story yeah yeah that was
interesting
not the sort of thing I do I'd rather
relive the shark attacks enjoyed growing
up I think as adults we forget how hard
it is being a kid and being a teenager
because back then you have no frame of
reference you have no idea how to deal
with anything everything is new every
stress is real it's only when you get
older that you realize off you know this
is just another thing I can get through
this but when you're a teenager right
rough
I mean you were just the way I read it
is you're a kid who just didn't connect
with school and have this lust for
adventure and excitement and because
maybe healthy options for how to pursue
that weren't necessarily totally
available to you you kind of went over
to the dark side for a while yeah well
it didn't start out that way normally
when I was younger I was okay at school
and when you're young you don't realize
that you're poor there's six people on a
policeman's wage in the 70s and 80s we
were doing it pretty tough month with
our brothers and sisters I'd myself my
two younger brothers and my baby sister
and mum was from Eastern London so we
ate sheeps brains and livers and kidneys
and all the garbage that no one else
wanted what part of Australia we were
down in Mornington Peninsula in
Melbourne about an hour and a half south
of Melbourne dad was away a lot with the
cops he was out late at nights and we
moved to Canberra which is the capital
of Australia when I was 10 and he got
posted and we all just sort of picked
and move and still going okay you know I
don't know how you guys call it well we
I got there about year five and year six
and then moved to an all-boys Catholic
school because my parents always made us
go to church what older boys went to
Catholic schools and that's where it
started to go downhill a little bit I
started getting picked on quite bad
because I was very short I was very
skinny I had big E's freckles all over
my face I was I was no an easy target
mm-hmm so it wasn't a lot of fun at
school but I was quite well-read
whenever dad went away with the cops and
he came home he'd always bring me a book
as a present sorry we had the you know
the full volume of Encyclopedia
Britannica from something like 1966 or
something
so I'd read all of those and I had this
wide knowledge of the world and how the
universe worked back in nineteen
somebody listening to this who was born
after you know 1980 is like what are you
talking yeah yeah yeah
so the Encyclopedia Britannica was like
how many volumes I don't know we had it
too oh man but it basically encompassed
all of the world's knowledge and so I
was well-read and I and I knew there was
adventure out there to be had and I grew
up on David Attenborough you know that
was my hero the guy that traveled the
world and saw all these crazy animals
and you what then you see you jnana
Jones and it's like oh my god this is a
crazy world out there and I so badly
want to see it and be a part of it but
I'm in Canberra and it sucks and
Canberra is very pretty to Canberra if
anyone who doesn't know is the capital
of Australia it's where all the
politicians hold Parliament it's also
funnily enough the only place in
Australia where weed pornography and
fireworks were decriminalized funny that
but I hit about 14 15 and I stopped
swimming because I was just hard had a
gut full of it I started like you're on
the swim team or whatever
yeah dad was the coach so he couldn't
really get out of it so we're up at five
o'clock in the morning before school
swimming a couple of Kay's every day and
then after school as well I mean both my
brothers are all state swimmers so I
stopped that I stopped running I was
doing I was a cross-country athlete and
I started looking at girls and started
smoking and drinking and because
marijuana was decriminalized there was a
bit of a floating around so I started
smoking weed as well hanging around
unsavory characters and I just fell deep
into it and at the same time I was
listening to Snoop Dogg and NWA well
before Snoop Dog's time you know NWA and
ice-t and all these west coast rappers
talking about smoking weed and hanging
out and I was just like yeah that sounds
cool and I sort of lost my focus for a
bunch of years there but I also think
you know Canberra or Canberra how do you
say in Canberra Canberra or anywhere
else like our school system just isn't
set up to really support somebody who
has that flair for adventure it's sort
of like you know what are you studying
for well you're gonna go to college and
you and here's the four careers that are
exact
mobile and for somebody who's got a wild
hair up their ass it's not like
developing that is anything that's
that's really kind of encouraged and on
top of that they don't teach for the
specific techniques of the people
learning
I had trouble like a lot of people too
reading what was on the blackboard while
the teacher was writing listening to the
teacher and writing in my book all at
the same time you know I'm I'm the
impeding me of a very poor multitask and
tasking man so I couldn't I couldn't
keep up with it all so I'm I'm writing
what's on the board but at the same time
I can't listen to the teacher because
I'm focused on this oh I'm I'm missing
out on something if I don't do that and
I listen to the teacher that I'm not
taking notes to study at home and it was
just all a mess and I just could not
keep up so the the techniques that they
used back then and still use in a lot of
schools today just they weren't right
for me so you start finding you know way
to you know find that adventure yeah
okay dope partying in line we were still
poor as well and we didn't have all the
cool stuff so I found a way to go and
get all that you just took it between
the lines I got I got busted we were
breaking into cars and breaking houses
very occasionally and shoplifting I got
caught shoplifting twice but I told him
my dad was a cop and they let me off no
then we go out drinking and I had a
fight with someone and I kicked a bus
shelter window in and ended up a night
in jail and it still still didn't give
me the kick and ass I just yeah as a cop
and you're the oldest one right yeah I
was place to be setting the example in
your ass he kicked my ass out at the
house mmm sorry I hit seventeen he's
just he called me in my friend's house
and he said I'm sick of your [ __ ] come
and get your stuff and [ __ ] off hmm
and I instantly had all of that freedom
that I wanted and I had no idea what to
do with it he split so where'd you go
I was very lucky that I had two friends
of mine from Indonesia two girls and
their parents paid for them they were
quite well-off
the parents paid for them to live and
study in Australia and they had their
own apartment so they took me and I
lived with them for about a year and a
half still didn't get my ass
Geir sat around smoking weed leading
their leftover Indonesian food and just
I look back on those days and I just I
wonder what the hell's our thinking how
could I be so down into that hole that I
don't realize I'm wasting my life away
and it just went on and it's probably
one of the the only regrets that I ever
have in life nothing else really just
wasting time because it's so valuable
and you never get it back and I spent
all of those those years not learning a
single thing and not growing as a person
all of those Domino's play into making
you the person that you are today
you know what I mean like perhaps you
wouldn't be doing what you're doing now
how do you not have that experience to
motivate you in a certain way to grow in
in later years well it's true there was
a moment where all of that came into
play where I was in hospital but I
finally got a job working at the lofty
heights of kitchen hand I think I was 19
or 20 and it was at one of the most
popular clubs in Canberra
so obviously lots of people go there's
lots of girls lots of drugs and I fell
down that hole for a little while as
well but eventually I came up I was just
about to turn 21 and I was living with a
couple of the guys from the club and I
went to a farewell for a friend of mine
who was being deported back to Papua New
Guinea no gettin kicked out of the
country for criminal activities
obviously he's one of my friends and so
at that party I got jumped by 20 guys
one guy was trying to get me to buy him
a drink and I was just telling him to
basically [ __ ] off and he threw a glass
of beer at me and I just thought that's
enough so I got up to have a go at him
and I I hit one guy one of his friends
that tried to pummel me in the face and
then all of their friends jumped up and
I just I ended up getting my house
really badly kicked and I went home and
I did I took that long hard look in the
mirror that your parents always tell you
to do I did I looked at my beaten up
broken face and I just thought
something's got to change or I'm gonna
be dead or in jail by the time I'm 23
and I didn't want that you know that I
still had this vision of this incredibly
adventurous world and so I did the only
thing I could think of which was remove
myself from that environment that I
become a product of and I threw
everything I owned into a tiny little
car that I had no license for and I'm
drove 12 hours up to the glimmering
lights of Brisbane well when you're from
Canberra Brisbane is pretty glimmering
yeah yeah and a friend of mine got a job
for me behind a bar in his strip club
that he was worried he was DJing at and
I started making rap music with his
flatmates to two American guys one was
from New Jersey one was from Pasadena
they were working at the record stores
they were running a community radio
station running night I like little hip
hop dance parties around the place and
making music and I grew up on the firm I
for the first cassette that I've ever
owned was Run DMC's tougher than leather
and then Ice T's iceberg and then NWA
and then Westside Connection it was that
was you know I had by that stage I had
about 340 cassettes in a box so I loved
rap music and so I just thought well
I've been listening in to it long enough
might as well start making some took a
little while has had like oh yeah kind
of a moment right yeah we put out an EP
and then off the back of that we got the
opening act for Snoop Dogg in in 98
which was incredible coming from little
old Melbourne a little picked on kid to
opening for Snoop Dogg was a pretty
brave step how is that music like online
anywhere
I think it's on iTunes but I'm not sure
if it's on American iTunes it may be be
strictly tied to Australian I played it
for my girlfriend in the car the other
day she was pissing herself but she also
she also said it was quite good she
expected worse but I wrote about the
things that I knew about so my song was
called smokin hydro but after that not a
lot of money in white rappers in
Brisbane in 1998
and the financial constraints ended up
taking its toll and the whole group just
imploded right and there you are just
working at a strip bar
I'd actually quit the strip club at that
point to focus on the music and so I had
nothing myself and my other friend from
Canberra who'd moved up there to work on
the music with us we were just stuck we
talked this real estate into letting us
live in one of their houses for four
weeks until we found another place and
my friend who's now a famous comic
artist you know has his own stalls at
Comic Con and stuff
he drew characters of the real estate
agents to pay our rent and we slept on
ripped couch cushions we showered at the
local pool because we had no water we
had no electricity
we ate off paper plates and ate two
minute noodles and that was it for weeks
and weeks and weeks
yeah yeah so did you have another moment
of looking in the mirror and go yeah
kind of I was just I was just thinking I
can't keep doing this you know I didn't
know where to go I was really lost I
tried to change my whole life and I
failed and I just thought where do I go
from here I don't know where else to
turn
and so well because when you moved to
Brisbane isn't this solution you took
yourself to Brisbane yeah I was the
problem but I was trying you know it
wasn't like I wasn't just moving and
then sitting on my ass again I was
really trying to grow as a person and
build a career and I thought that was in
rapping and it wasn't but that like we
do sometimes when we were a little bit
lost you turn to the person that will
always be there for you and I called mum
and I keep been in communication with
your parents during this time or a
little bit by that stage yeah dad and I
had not made up we hadn't talked but I'd
been talking to my mum occasionally once
you know once we started I was working
in the industry club and making some
money and I felt a little more achieved
and she just said we'll talk to your
brothers they've both joined the
military it should be noted that one of
them joined the army to stay out of jail
he followed you my foot yeah probably
yeah
forcefully but you know I did all right
there's no point asking for advice and
they're not following it up so I talked
to my brothers and they said yeah look
it's great you know you get that we're
both in artillery so they said you get
paid to travel you get paid to play
sport you get to hang out with your
mates you get to shoot guns and rockets
and cannons one thing they said though
was don't join infantry so I joined
infantry why did they say that though
because it's just hard it's it's no it's
the hardest job physically in the
military and they just didn't think that
I'd be able to do it so they were trying
to convince me to go into something a
little simpler where I wouldn't get
kicked out and so that was that decision
to do that in defiance of them or what
was the motivation to go the harder
route it was a little bit in defiance to
them but to me I didn't see it as the
harder route I saw it as if you join the
army you join as a soldier that's the
definition of being a soldier you
everyone has their different opinions
and I agree artillery and everyone is
part of the military working system but
being a soldier
there's something really prideful in
that that you as an infantry grunt you
stand a little taller and you wear that
uniform with a little more pride because
you know that if you go to war you're
going to be up there in the front seats
you know trading bullets with the enemy
so that's where I want it to be right
that sense of adventure was like I'm not
sitting back there shooting cannons at
people I want to be up there fighting
and so I did that and I passed basic
training which was a surprise to
everyone the biggest surprise was to my
friends that the army actually gave me a
gun I mean you're all jacked up right
now but were you still like a like a
skinny that point I was like nothing I
was a yes what do you guys I was gonna
call it a paddle pop stick do you guys
like and what do you guys call popsicle
stick yeah
I was tiny I had no I could not keep fat
on my body I ate like an animal but from
all the years of running and swimming I
just couldn't keep any muscle or fat on
so I was worried though I was strong I
could walk forever I could run forever
past basic training past employment
training for the infantry and at the end
of that they said you know who wants to
jump out of a plane mm-hmm and I'd never
been accused of doing anything too
clever so I put my hand in the air with
this goofy expression on my face it's a
yell and they went congratulations
you're gonna be a paratrooper and I just
thought that sounds badass yeah and so
it was off to Sydney first time to
Sydney to be a newest soldier at the
third Battalion Royal Australian
regiment parachute battalion and I got
my ID when I did my parachute course got
my maroon beret made me stand even
taller and I just felt this incredible
sense of achievement and one of the
biggest turning points there was when I
was doing my my psych evaluation before
I joined the army and I passed
everything I passed the aptitude testing
I pass the medical and I finally passed
the psych evaluation and as I was
walking out of the room the doctor said
good luck with your career and it hit me
that I had this thing called a career
that I never thought I would have to me
a career was like what a lawyer had an
adductor and now something you can build
on and you can grow you can never
underestimate the power of one word in
changing someone's whole mindset about
something I thought [ __ ] me I'm gonna
have a career this is real I have a real
job that I can be proud of and that
powered me through some of the darkest
days being an infantry soldier is not
easy a 10-mile fighting withdrawals in
full gas
suits and gas masks in the middle of the
night in pouring rain with a hundred and
twenty pound pack on your back and
things like that but you remember why
you're doing it and it drives you on
you're doing it for your mates and what
so what year's work was this that I
joined the Army in November 2005 2000
and I stayed there until April 2005 and
how did you not get deployed I did once
okay so Afghanistan I got deployed to a
place called East Timor and most people
have never even heard of this place it's
a small Southeast Asian island
half of it is owned by Indonesia and the
other half is owned by the natives they
steam Ares and there's a thin you know
river that separates the two from each
other
except the Indonesians didn't care about
that and they were going over and
slaughtering these people I the the
stats was 250,000 of them were killed
murdered starved and died of illnesses
I've never even heard that yeah yeah it
was really bad so Australia went in a
multinational force went in under the
United Nations Australia played the
biggest role because it was so close to
us and we went in there and I spent six
months in 2002 patrolling that border to
keep the Indonesians out you know
kidnapping soldiers that cross the
border and interrogating them went on
snipers course did airborne repelling
out at the Blackhawks and just a lot of
it was boring a lot of the society
action or was it just no no they recon
and the Indonesians that there was a lot
of rumors going around about the
Australians and one of them was that we
ate babies so the Indonesian soldiers in
East Timor were not too confident in
dealing with us so that one of the guys
of we kidnapped and took up into the
mountains because he was stealing money
from the locals
we sat him on the edge of a cliff while
we discuss where we were gonna take him
and he was praying and he was crying he
thought we're gonna just shoot him in
the head and kick him off the edge of
the cliff was we would never do that
right you're some kind of savage yeah
exactly but you know that's in part to
what the special forces guys did when
they went in there first off there were
some pretty hairy moments when they were
dealing with the Indonesians in those
periods like you know one of the New
Zealand Maori SAS guys got got captured
and they cut off his ears and cut off
his nose and cut off his head and all
this stuff so the museum
an sas commander just said off you go
boys and is that conflict still going on
it the conflict itself isn't going on
but there is civil unrest still there a
nation that is divided by a political
system which is very common all around
the world obviously you can now you can
still you can go there you can go to
Delhi the capital of East Timor which is
where a lot of the major conflict was
and you can go there as a tourist so
it's not hugely dangerous it's not like
Papua New Guinea one of the most
dangerous places in the world that most
people have never heard of also so that
was a huge turning point for me right
but then you decide you don't want to
stay in the army right yeah well I just
look I hadn't seen action but I'd done
my job for real and it made me realize
made me appreciate so much for starters
I'd never been to a third world country
before I never even been overseas before
that so I was seeing these people raking
through our rubbish with homemade rakes
and we'd set the rubbish on fire mind
you and just to salvage whatever they
could people with nothing but they were
happy and they collected their water in
the street or washed in the river but
that was still happy and I went home
with this appreciation of everything
that we have especially a toilet and a
shower and just healthy food and not
having malaria all of that stuff and so
I was like oh I want to do it again I
want to do my job for real and I got
asked to go to Iraq I mean it me and one
of my teams and they cancelled the trip
four days before we left and so that
just kind of crushed us all and I just
thought little stuff this I'm gonna go
somewhere where I can get deployed and
I'd heard about these guys called
clearance divers I didn't really know
much about him I knew they were a bit
special they're a little like that SAS
and the commandos no one looked directly
at them right it's sort of like a
Special Forces SEAL team kind of
situation it's similar to that but it
doesn't come under the Special Forces
umbrella we
only have SAS and commandos and they
fall under SOCOM Special Operations
Command as a clearance diver you can go
and join a unit called the tactical
assault group for the East Coast and
that's the commandos and the clearance
divers working together as a
counterterrorism unit which is very cool
that's very fun job lots and lots of
shooting in gas masks and heckler & koch
mp5 s and very accurate close quarters
shooting it's a lot of fun blowing up
doors killing terrorists yeah but uh so
I get excited about that stuff
but like it's I think of it sort of like
the frogman yeah I guess the seals are
now the the antecedent of the frogman
exactly.the you know like being
specialized in you know water tactics
they were referred to as Navy divers or
clearance divers but unlike America we
don't have as many people in our
military branches so as clearance divers
we have to do everything we do the
salvage and repair that we do the mine
countermeasures underwater we do the
land-based explosive ordnance disposal
we do the maritime tactical operations
you know attack swimming in the middle
of the night reconnaissance swimming on
pure oxygen rebreathers using the
minimum magnetic rebreathers to dive
deep and deal with anti acoustic
anti-seismic anti diver tampering device
mines all this crazy [ __ ] I understand
about five percent of what you decide
what I'm imagining is you know Hurt
Locker underwater exactly yeah it's a
lot of fun I was living my dream line
this is the elite of our Navy and the
training I read a little bit about what
the training is like for for you know
getting into that I mean it's super
intense yeah it's it's you like swimming
across Sydney Harbour in the middle of
the night yeah five or six hours and
then followed by five-hour PT sessions
on the soft sand stretcher carries pack
marches first-aid stands mind games
breath hold on and on and on and on for
ten days
and I I was talking about one of my
Chiefs the other day and the course was
called see that they've changed the name
of it something now but I was asking him
um how it was going because they were
running a selection prop course and he
goes oh it's got a pretty good where we
started at 42 we're down to 17 and I
said oh well what day is that
day - yeah 50% we lose most of the
people on day one because you turn up
and you get your issues and then you
break straight into PT and it's this
grueling 5 hour run session and you
finally make it back to the dive school
that's dark you're hurting you get
probably five minutes to stretch and
rehydrate and then they say all right
boys line up we're doing it again
hmm and that's whenever I just yeah and
you're wearing these high vis Blazers
and people just not they take it off and
they hand it in and they're out of there
yeah but you had been a runner and you'd
been a swimmer so yeah like sort of
sorted out you were good to go yeah but
you know I still for some reason I
didn't believe in all of these fancy
sneakers and all this fancy gear all the
guys had I just had this beat-up pair of
old converse that I used to run in and I
turned up and they're like oh look at
this
army guy in his converse like straight
up those flat bottom yeah like like
nasca Paul Cameron yeah nothing just
they just and they've got all their
fancy adidas Brooks and what-have-you
and they're kind of like chuckling at me
and then we jumped in the water or went
for a run and I smoked them all and I
was the second oldest on the course I
was 28 by that stage and they were all
21 22 23 but you don't hurt you'd have
the army training also exactly that's
all that is realized prepared and my
feet you know after doing two days of
pack marching they all collapse in their
bunks and they're all taping up their
toes and strapping tape one of the guys
have to tape up both of his balls I just
took my boots off and went to sleep
because I don't resist a pack marching
every day well you're probably going to
get up in an hour anyway
exactly
so you're finding your groove like this
is this is working for ya man I hate I
was eight thirty years old and I was
just living my dream I was living down
at Bondi Beach I was riding a big black
Italian sports black I was traveling the
world with my mates shooting guns and
blowing stuff up and then you turn to
work one day and a [ __ ] shark eats
you right so let's let's walk through it
let's walk through that day yeah it was
early in the morning we were doing a
counterterrorism exercise the the goal
was to test this new equipment that the
R&D department of the military had
created it was unmanned video and sonar
designed to detect attack swimmers and
attack divers coming in to put bombs on
our ships and equipment so they set it
up on the PR in Sydney Harbor along the
alongside the Navy base and it's very
central to everything you can see the
Harbour Bridge it's not that far away
the Opera House that everyone knows
about you can see all that and just out
there last year and I took one of those
fairies so I was visualizing it
perfectly yeah so when you're moving
away from the Sydney Opera House and
that's behind you on your right-hand
side yeah and you get to that fort in
the middle of the harbor for Denison so
if you look 45 degree angle over to the
Navy base right by the pier right there
is where I got attained no one has been
attacked in Sydney Harbor in 60 years at
that point no no that was it that was
kind of a banner year though overall for
shark attack were like 21 that year I
think that was a it was a little less
than that but there was a guide the day
after me at Bondi which is you know as
the crow flies probably five miles away
and he lost his hand as well so I've got
the new guy in the water he's pretending
to be an attack swimmer all the Rd guys
and my chief are up on the bow of one of
the warships watching and this
equipments on the P trying to detect him
and he's swimming around for about half
an hour and I thought I'd do him a good
turn I said jump out mate I'll take over
for you you know I rolled over the edge
of the little black
zodiac in a black wetsuit and a pair of
fins and I was doing what we call
finning I was on my back on the surface
just kicking my legs and it was a 3-tier
thing we were gonna do surf or swimming
to see if it could detect us we're gonna
do scuba to see if it could detect us
and then pure oxygen rebreathers with no
bubbles to see if we could detect that
so we're still in the first phase yeah
this is 40 minutes into testing and the
form the very first day and I'm in the
water on the surface almost it's like
this is simple routine chair this is
nothing this is like the boringest day
ever and I to get up at 4 o'clock in the
morning for this [ __ ]
so it's end of February February 11 so
the start of February which is the end
of summer for us it's probably the
hottest season of the year but it was
kind of chilly it was overcast the
waters murky in Sydney Harbour so
combining all of that you can't see
through the water at all and I'm one of
my first runs towards one of the
warships that I'm you know pretending to
attack and I look over my left shoulder
to make sure that I'm going in the right
direction and before I can turn back I
just get this massive whack in my leg
like someone's hit me with a baseball
bat and it didn't really hurt it was
just surprising more than anything else
and I turned around to see what it was
thinking the guys in the boat maybe got
too close I couldn't hear cuz I had
water in my ears and I turn around and
my brain couldn't comprehend what I was
seeing
because I had never seen a shark's head
up close in real life like that before
and it took me a few seconds and I I
thought oh [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] shark and
all these things ran through my head and
I thought okay okay okay I've seen I've
seen the Crocodile Hunter I've seen
Discovery Channel I'll jab it in the
eyeball right and so I tried hunch it in
the face right that people have said it
works
I just thought eyeball because that's
the softest spot so I tried but I
couldn't move my arm for some reason and
I looked down and I could see all the
teeth half embedded into my thigh I
could see the lips pulled back all the
pink gums and the teeth going all the
way up my leg over my wrist which was
by my side so it had my hand in its
mouth which is why I couldn't move it
and it's still at this point it didn't
hurt I could see the teeth embedded in
my hand on I just thought okay left hand
so I reached for the eyeball but had me
by the back of the leg and I I was
inches away from that eyeball just
desperately trying to get my finger in
it but I couldn't reach so I tried to
grab it by the nose and push it off sort
of lever it off that way but all that
did was push the teeth of the lower jaw
deeper into my hamstring so I stopped
that and I cocked back to give it a
whack in the nose and just as I was
coming in it started to shake me and
this all-encompassing pain rattled me to
my core and all the strength went out of
my punch and I yelled and I think that's
when the guys in the safety boat saw
what was going on and when it's shaking
you the lower jaw detaches right and it
goes side to side so it comes like this
sawing effect on yeah it's it's movable
so that yeah it just basically was
sawing the flesh out of my body
while I'm in agony terrified drowning
this is my worst nightmare I was
terrified of sharks really the only two
things are scared of with sharks and
public speaking so and now this is your
life I know it's Regis [ __ ] that's the
way the universe works it out man yeah
you know you'll your greatest fears can
actually become your greatest strengths
and I think at the end that's really the
theme of your of your whole story yeah
you know you gotta embrace that [ __ ]
mm-hmm because you don't know you don't
you're not fully aware of what you can
accomplish if you're letting especially
if you're letting fear hold you back
mm-hmm and to be confronted with that in
the most vicious life-threatening way
possible I mean it's just it's it's
beyond imagination you know and and I've
seen that there's photographs online you
can see the pictures of your arm
yeah the actual attack video is on
YouTube yeah yeah it looks like that i
watch that and it's sort of like a loch
ness monster thing it's all like grainy
and you're like what's actually going
you can't really tell what's going on
but those still photographs of your
armed and in the back of your leg are
just yeah and then I know when you got
appetite you tight you say like you show
these pictures and some of that and like
50 guys like passed out yeah 50 I really
use 53 people of pasta 51 men only two
women man yeah I mean it's as gruesome
as it comes that image of your arm is I
almost wish I didn't see it I don't
think I've had any pass out in America
though I'm heading up to Atlanta to talk
to IBM on Sunday so I'm wondering if I'm
gonna get my first American casualty
yeah I'm a little bit worried though
because you guys like to see people give
the warning I do I give the warning I
make very light hearted of it we have a
good time but some people just tell him
to turn away I do one of the guys said
he wasn't even watching he said he just
listened to me speaking any passed-out
me that guy needs to hear your message a
little bit more than yeah yeah but it's
a lot of fun
not that day though that was not fun at
all so so there you are
these guys are hauling you out you know
it's interesting that that like
fight-or-flight response typically you
hear that the pain comes later you know
because the adrenaline is so you know on
on overdrive in the situation but you
are already feeling the pain I mean yeah
the the the amount of blood that you
were losing I mean I it's it's shocking
that you're alive like it's incredible
that you didn't just bleed out yeah but
it's testament to what the human body is
capable of when I was be super capable
guys you know the exact best guys ever
yeah like you know deal with the
situation and to be you know calm under
fire yep
well one of the guys hadn't even slept
that night he was actually hungover as
hell passed out in the bottom of the
boat you imagine waking up to your buddy
being eaten by a shark and having to do
first aid you know a lot of the guys
literally reached his hand in and like
pinched an artery yeah right yeah
because they couldn't stop the bleeding
they put a tonic how on using the strap
from a life jacket because we didn't
have any medical equipment we didn't
think it was going to be a day like that
at all because this is where we work
every day
so one of the guys the new guy who I'd
pulled out of the water earlier I had to
stick his hand inside my leg and pinch
closed an artery otherwise I would have
died and it should have been that guy
right he were like we're swapping out
for him well everyone was saying that if
it was him there's no way he would have
lived
he was much smaller than me the shark
would have killed him so maybe it was
for a reason mmm well unconsciously
maybe
yes all right so so you're rushed to the
hospital they save your life walk me
through this next phase of this ordeal I
remember I remember waking up one point
and looking down and seeing that my foot
was still there and that was that was
pretty a pretty big deal I thought well
you know I've seen my hands gone I've
processed that there's nothing I can do
about I'm very realistic person I
generally don't let emotions get away
with me and I've used that as a I guess
a coping mechanism for quite some time
so I'm just thinking okay hands gone but
if I can keep my leg then maybe life
will go on as normal maybe I can keep
this job that I love so much and then I
passed out again and the next time I
woke up all my family and friends were
there and had that you know worried
trying to be smiley positive faces on
and I had tubes all down my throat so I
couldn't talk and I made up this board
for me with letters so I could type tap
out the words I wanted to say my first
words were [ __ ] shark which made them
all laugh but I was more about trying to
ease their worry than anything else
because I was drug to the eyeballs so I
couldn't feel anything I was in a very
jovial state and I still have my legs
they crush you with vicodin in the in
the boat right no we didn't have
anything oh yeah no nothing so no so the
the pain went away basically as soon as
the shark had ripped out my hamstring
and ripped off my hand and swam away
because it took all the nerves with it
so I knew what was going on because I
got to the surface and I started to try
and swim back to the boat and I saw my
hand was gone didn't know how bad my leg
was because I couldn't move it I was
swimming back to the
by with one hand in one leg through a
pool of my own blood I've got my right
arm above my heart to stand in that
video you can tell like you're swimming
back to the to the boat yeah with the
the step of my arm out of the water
trying to stem the bleeding above my
heart and so and you you were able to
maintain consciousness or yeah pass out
no I had to I had to get back to that
but I didn't think I was gonna make it I
thought the shark was gonna come and
kill me but the guys got to me I passed
out once I got into the boat but then
one of the guys thought I was going into
cardiac arrest so he started pummeling
me in the heart in the chest to wake me
back up and it worked and I woke up and
I'm like oh hands freakin being eaten
off by a shark I look up and my buddy's
beating the [ __ ] out of me I'm just
thinking today's [ __ ] and the pain
still didn't kick in at that point I was
cracking jokes I was till I was looking
at my buddies saying hey so you reckon
you can get someone to look after my
motorbike because I don't think I'm
riding at home today and the pain
difficult military guy the human body is
amazing that it has defense mechanisms
that can that can put you into that kind
of State yeah survive it's an incredible
thing I was just trying to focus on
anything except dying right and we
should say cuz I don't think we did it
was a nine-foot bull shark yeah right
yeah and what is it you know what's the
difference between a bull shark and a
great way a [ __ ] bull sharks are
generally smaller than great whites
they're much more aggressive I was told
by people that they have more
testosterone than an adult bull elephant
they will bite first ask questions later
they will investigate with their mouths
they'd like to live in murky waters they
can live in saltwater and freshwater and
they've found all the you know one of
them was found 1500 kilometers or miles
up the Kentucky River I think it was so
all those years of going up thinking
that swimming in the river you were safe
oh now I see them in a very different
light right but we're gonna get into
that yeah there's there's a lot of bull
sharks in Sydney Harbor and we knew that
were there they just never bothered us
so eventually has there been any
attacks in Sydney Harbor since no mm-hmm
no but the pain really didn't come on
strong again until the ambulance got
there and then they started banging the
morphine in they gave me so much they
couldn't give me anymore and I was still
in agony and but my I was my blood was
at such a low level that I didn't have
any oxygen I didn't have any energy and
I was physically having trouble making
my chest go up and down so I could suck
in air so I had to get coached through
that as well because I actually thought
I was gonna die from suffocation but
that didn't happen either thankfully had
some good paramedic coaches helping me
breathe and I spent a week in hospital
with my leg thinking and hoping that I
might be able to keep it but every day
my foot got a little bit darker and a
little less lifelike and I started to
prepare myself mentally and emotionally
for for having to lose it and the
surgeon came in one day and broke it all
down for me told me exactly what was
going on with the leg you know 25
centimeters of this sciatic nerve was
gone the whole hamstring was gone I
would never be able to move it or feel
it again but I could keep it mhm and I
just thought there's no way I don't want
to carry that unfeeling unmoving lump of
was around with me around yeah I'm gonna
have this huge chunk missing out of the
back of my leg my fitness will suffer my
motivation my happiness or suffer and I
I don't want that I just want to get on
with life and so I decided to have the
leg removed and that was pretty bad
actually afterwards I was dead like they
had you all jacked up on ketamine and
you were like turned me into the
Terminator that was my mind said I'm
just like doc take my leg and tow me in
a determinate well two things first of
all you can't are the Terminator
incredibly badass you know appendages
now that that are I mean you're
literally the bionic man you know like
those are some high end yeah this is the
best is it yeah I'm very lucky up
thankfully I don't have to pay for it
the leg is I think two hundred thousand
dollars it's got a running mode it's
waterproof
really really good stuffs got six micro
processors in it I don't know what any
of that [ __ ] does but like when you
shook my hand like your fingers yeah
then yeah it's good how does that is
there like something on the end of your
it's all in the socket Wow so the hand
is all the mechanics in the socket that
goes up to my elbow there's the brain
they call it the battery's like two
little phone batteries and then two
sensors one on the top on the inside and
one on the bottom on the inside of the
sock and they press against my skin
they're in exact spots where I have
strong forearm muscle activation so if I
say I pretend to make a fist and then I
pull my fist back towards the top of my
arm and flex that top arm muscle that
activates the hand to open if I want to
close it I flex it the other way force
it down and it closes Wow you take a
little while to wire your brain to be
able to send those signals properly yeah
yeah because I hadn't used them in so
long your muscles cramp up because
you're constantly trying to flex them
and then you can't rub them out because
you've got this hard carbon fiber socket
over it so a lot of painful days with
the leg muscles cramping up that you
can't get to but and other like
foundations that pay for that like how
does that all work
I was military sorry I say in the
military paid for it to begin with and
then once I left the military three
years later Veteran Affairs started
looking after it all right very lucky
right alright so the other thing I
wanted to mention is you know and you
and you were counting this you're like I
just wanted to get on with my life
that's I have to believe that on some
level that's a function of the mental
and emotional training that you received
in military because the more predictable
human response would be like I don't
want to live or like you know just more
of a giving up kind of impulse I think
the drugs helped I'm not gonna lie the
ketamine mixed with morphine I think
you're right but it more so came into
play about two days later because
immediately after I had my leg removed
they that couldn't control the pain they
were jacking me up on so many drugs and
nothing was stopping me stopping the
pain I was
jacked up on ketamine going down the K
hole I was on morphine that put me back
in general population instead of the
little quiet corner I was in so all I
could see was this curtain around my bed
my legs gone in agony my hands gone I
can eat all these voices in visiting
hour the guy in the bed next to me
sounded like he was dying I'm tripping
out I mean agony and all I wanted to do
was die I had in those 20 hours of pain
it lasted in those 20 hours all I wanted
to do was die I wished that the shark
had killed me I even asked my mom to go
and find me a gun so I could kill myself
this was my absolute lowest point ever
in my life and I wouldn't wish this
feeling on another human soul but
fortunately I got through it I got
through the twenty hours and after that
I was laying in my bed thinking okay
what now what am I going to do and it
was just such a complicated situation
but I hate complicated situations it's
they're too bloody complicated I like
things to be simple and I feel like a
lot of times in our lives we over
complicate things when most things can
be broken down to a simple choice so I
made a simple choice what do I want
do I want a good life or drawn a bad
life it's the fundamental choice that
you get to have what do I want that's
our power it's the only real power we
have is our choice so I thought okay
well obviously I want a good life
because no one's willingly going to go
and have a bad life unless you're
special so I'm thinking good life okay
how do I do that what am I going to do I
can't even get up out of this bed how am
I going to fast rope out of a helicopter
they're never gonna let me play with
explosives my whole career is based on
the fact that I can do anything that
these people ask me to do and now I
can't so what am I going to do and I
thought well I can sit here and I can
cry myself to sleep and I can wallow in
my self-pity and say Paul Paul
woe is me and I could get addicted to my
amazed
pain meds at our self-administering I
can push all of this love and support
that I was being given away and people
from around the world I didn't even know
was sending me letters of support I
could just reject it all or I could do
what the military trained me to do I
could pick myself up dust myself off and
get on with the job I could use all of
that love and support that I was being
given use that as a tool and I could
look at the great things I still had in
my life and the great things I still had
yet to achieve and have a good life it
seems like you you ran that calculus in
an incredibly compressed period of time
because when you listen to other people
that have suffered the loss of limbs or
you know whether it's you know veterans
coming back from battle like they avenge
them you know the ones that you hear
about who are out inspiring the world
like they eventually get to that place
but more often than not there's months
you know or long extended periods of
time where there is that wallowing in
self-pity and all of that before they
can kind of get it together to move
forward yeah well I knew the hardest
part was still to come
so I didn't have time to waste on all
that deciding [ __ ] like I said I'm a
very realistic person and I just I knew
what I wanted to do because I was scared
I was really scared of losing my career
and everything that I felt completed my
identity so I needed to work straight
away now two days after I had my leg
chopped off I'm trying to train in my
bed I'm doing one-armed chin-ups on the
bar above my bed when the doctor walks
in and as I what the [ __ ] you do blow
out his stitches but there was no way I
was going to stop no I I had a goal I
had a huge big ridiculous goal of being
allowed to go back to work and now you
make like a conscious decision to come
to maybe compartmentalize it's not the
right word but to sort of train yourself
to focus on that forward path and not
dwell it was it like a second nature
thing because of the training that you
had or was it like a practice that you
had to kind of you know cajole yourself
into getting into that
I had to remind myself a lot and one of
the reminders was exactly what we were
talking about before remembering how low
I had been in the past
remembering the days of sitting on the
couch day after day stoned out in my
brain
remembering what it's like to live in a
house with no electricity no running
water you know and swearing to yourself
you will not go back to that anything is
better than that so you just work your
ass off right and you said that you
regret all that time wasted as a kid but
now you're relying on that memory to
empower you forward exactly that's a
duality of what you you needed that
experience in order for you to weather
this storm it's funny how life works out
so you you sort of launch yourself
immediately into this rehab situation
and you're like doing push-ups and all
kinds of things and stuff like right
okay my doctor actually whenever he gave
me because I had to kick continue going
in for new surgeries had another surgery
on my hand another surgery another three
surgeries on my leg and he would double
the amount of time he told me that I had
to recover and not do pt because he knew
I was gonna have it and try and heal
twice as fast so I spent nine weeks in
hospital training the whole time my
family and friends were amazing that
brought me weights and protein powders
and i sweet-talked the nurses into
giving me double rations because I
needed I'd lost ten kilos in ten seconds
so I needed to bulk up and get strong
again and I read constantly I had to
keep my mind active so that I wouldn't
dwell on the [ __ ] I knew that was
gonna be the biggest thing so what were
you reading I was reading Dan Millman's
peaceful warrior yeah amazing that
really changed my perception a very good
friend of mine
Tania Morrison gave me that and what did
you get out of that like what was the
applicable like tool it was the idea
that you are limitless that your mind is
far more powerful than anything you can
imagine and you need to listen to it you
have to listen to your body as well
obviously when you
injuries and you know what that's like
after doing five lineman but your mind
is the is de hammer your body is the
nail and if you can remain motivated and
positive through your mind reminding
yourself that you're limitless and you
are strong and you can do things that
you tell yourself you can't do you know
that's you telling your brain instead of
your brain telling you that you can
achieve all this [ __ ] so just trust in
it and if you say to yourself I can do
this I'm going to do this just [ __ ]
do it
mmm don't think too much about it don't
dwell because that's when you let doubt
creep in but also the sense that you are
not your body and you are not your mind
I mean this is for warriors very much a
spiritual thought yeah you know I mean
there's some crazy out there [ __ ] up
but I mean that that has you thinking
more broadly about what consciousness is
and and what the kind of you know your
universal flow of energy means and how
to kind of leverage that yep it's been a
few years since I read that book I need
to touch that again he's done a few
since then as well as he yeah
but it just it got me on the path to
where I needed to be instead of worrying
about what was to come I was setting
goals and challenges for what was to
come and I was worried about the pity
and the people staring and not having a
hand in a leg and so when you worry and
you do that you do something about it so
I got onto the internet they wanted the
Navy wanted me to talk to a counselor
and I didn't want to talk to some person
I didn't know about how I was feeling
because I already knew how I was feeling
[ __ ] I didn't want to talk about it I
just wanted to know that it's like
classic classic military cop like you
didn't a cop shows you know when there's
a shooting and then they make him go
talk to the shrink and they don't want
to say anything yeah it wasn't like an
alpha male thing it wasn't that I didn't
want to deal with it it was just that I
was already dealing with it I already
knew what I needed to do so I didn't
need to waste time talking to someone
about it so I got onto YouTube and I got
onto Google and I used technology to
help me you can the wealth of the
world's knowledge is in a few keystrokes
so I started Google
what is the greatest prosthetics in the
world what hands are out there what legs
are out there and I got onto YouTube and
I started watching these videos of
Paralympic athletes doing ridiculously
amazing things and that started to give
me hope that if they can do it there's
no reason that I can't do it as well I'm
gonna have the military in my corner
paying for these prosthetics so I might
as well try and get the best that I can
right and so so what have I got to worry
about and I would presume that when
you're in this you know rehabilitation
phase you're in some kind of center
where there's a lot of other veterans
that are dealing with something similar
right no no we didn't it's not like
America we don't have huge big military
hospitals it was a wing of the general
public hospital so there wasn't anybody
else kind of going through the same
thing that you were going through they
did at least connect with and I was the
only one mmm yeah everyone else is a
huge story in Australia yeah I was like
a major they went all over the world I
was getting letters from kids in Germany
and France and Italy but yeah it was
pretty massive because like we said that
no one had been attacked instantly
Harbor in 60 years so there was media
all over it and luckily my family were
dealing with that at the end of the the
nine weeks in hospital sixty minutes
came and wanted to do a story I did two
of those that the reporter became a very
good friend of mine and we went and dive
with sharks together and yeah but after
after six months I went back to the Navy
and asked them if I could go back to
work and they said no and they said to
go to the diving teams you have to be
deployable for war and obviously you're
not deploy before I said well look I get
that that's fine I'm not a Swift on my
feet anymore and my trigger finger
doesn't work all the time so what I can
do though is I can go and pass on this
knowledge that you've given to me and
you know I the the movie man of honor
with Cuba Gooding jr. and Robert De Niro
it's like a staple and so I'm just like
he went and taught diving I'll just go
on
each doll having his meme rationalizing
in my head like haha exactly and so they
said I okay well look you can go and
teach at the school three half days a
week and so I went five full days a week
and just didn't leave and I I really
felt that I needed to prove myself and
prove that I deserve to be there so I
just busted my ass every day and I did
that for three years and I was literally
killing myself
it was so hard trying to keep up with
everyone also maintain my training and
the long hours we were doing we'd be at
work at 6 o'clock in the morning
sometimes finish it two o'clock in the
morning and then have to be back there
at 6 and it was just wiping me out and I
went to my boss at the dive school one
day and asked him what the chances of me
moving back to the dive teams or
somewhere else for divers was and he
said zero and so that was when I decided
that I was going to leave the military
and that was terrifying how long ago was
that that was I left August 2012
officially I stayed part of the Navy
Reserve diving team and continued to do
work with them but it was on my own
terms and the idea then I mean are you
looking at like ok I mean you have all
this sort of notoriety in Australia
right yeah not by that stage you know
this is three years later so it had all
of the media stuff it had settled down a
bit
but I did get asked I'd started speaking
a little bit and nothing terrified me
more than that but and I turned down
speaking jobs while I was in the Navy
but a group called canteen which is a
group for kids with cancer they asked me
to talk to their kids at a camp and I
just thought well I don't want to but
how do you say no to kids with cancer so
I thought alright and I put this little
presentation together and I went in and
did it and I made these kids laugh and I
made them forget that they were sick and
forget that they grew up in a hospital
ward and it made me feel so good to make
them feel so good and it was this
realization
I wanted that feeling again you know it
was like serving my country coming home
and and feel like oh my god that was
amazing I walked out of that room
feeling on top of the world and so I
went from there to my old school I did
30 kids and then went to 1200 at my old
school which was a terrifying again
there were some of the same teachers
there yeah yeah that look like he's
leading me around the school like I
always knew Paul would be something
great I'm like dude you used to kick me
in my ass and where's your dad in this
whole thing dad's still back in Canberra
at that point not actually he was um he
was working in Abu Dhabi I in the UAE so
he was working for customs integrating a
lot of their computer systems so they'd
talk to each other mum was still in
things with you a long time ago yeah we
around my sister's sister's 18th
birthday party me and a few of the army
boys rode down on our motorbikes and we
sat around and I had a few beers with my
dad for the first time and that was
squashed at all that's so Australia but
yeah it was just a moment came when I
was talking to those two hundred twelve
hundred kids at my old school and my mum
had come and my best friend had come and
I stopped halfway through and before I
went onstage the principal was talking
everyone all the kids are coughing and
spluttering and talking about how he is
you can't hear anything and then I get
up to talk and halfway through I stop
and it's dead silent like you can you
can't hear a single thing you could
literally hear a pin drop and I looked
at my friend and he's like wide-eyed
looking around going holy [ __ ] this is
crazy and so I continued on and it just
gave me this know this sense that I was
making a difference you know all of
their lives at once and that made me
feel pretty amazing and maybe I can help
them through some of the the crap that I
went through and guide them around the
obstacles so I continued on and I just
started getting paying jobs and it
turned into this whole big career and
that's why I felt comfortable leaving
the military
terrified because I didn't know how long
are you the flavor flavor of the month
how long is this do I want to be ten
years down the track I was a little
worried about once it all fizzled out
what I was gonna do I just figured I
well I can't live in Sydney on my
pension but I could probably live in
Vietnam like a king so that's still my
fallback plan
yeah but the irony is that quite the
opposite has occurred yeah and I think
there's something you know beautiful and
magical about what happens when you give
yourself over to service right I mean
obviously this this impulse to serve is
nourishing you and giving you a sense of
purpose and fulfillment
you know perhaps on an even more
profound deeper level than anything you
had done prior and to trust that and to
say like I'm just gonna keep I'm gonna
keep doing this and when you're in that
spirit and action of giving of yourself
for the betterment of others in my
experience and what I've seen with other
people the universe shows up Oh Oh 100%
I I've become a firm believer in
whatever you want to call it the
universe karma everything great that I
have in my life now is because of things
that I've done selflessly and it's
people like well you can't just do
things to get things back now that you
know that I I know I know I don't I
actually really really enjoy doing
things and expecting nothing I like to
help people that I know will never be
able to do anything for me I walk my dog
for instance down this little lane way
down at Marina del Rey and there's
rubbish everywhere and I hated it
bothers me so much as cigarette butts
and so I started picking up the
cigarette butts I take one of my doggie
bags and poop bags and I start picking
up all the rubbish all on this little
walkway and now I walk down there and
it's clean it's amazing and the last day
that I did it I got down to the beach
and I met this guy and he gave me free
tickets to The Comedy Store mm-hmm you
know just a little thank you he's along
the way like yeah karma coming quick
yeah exactly and now I have this out I
would
change a thing I wouldn't take my hand
in my leg back to have my old life back
that's that amazing thing so you like
that was what I wanted to kind of work
towards like this idea that this
gratitude that you have for that
experience as opposed to you know why me
yeah
not enough I'd call it gratitude it it
definitely but gratitude for the life
that you you the gratitude for the life
I have right now
it's ridiculous I live in LA did you
know I have a view of the ocean and I
was in Bondi last year and I was like
this is pretty good yeah definitely hang
out here yeah you can see while I was
living my dream yeah at that point and I
still love I'm heading back to Bondi and
a couple of weeks to do some speaking
jobs I loved it there but this is
America this is like everything you see
in the movies like I was watching
Goliath with them what's the guy's name
used to date Angelina Jolie it's a
series with Billy Ray Thornton with the
Wraith on his right Billy Bob Billy Bob
Thornton and they're filming this show
called life all through Santa Monica and
I'm like oh I go there to drink oh I go
there to eat and it's just it's such a
surreal experience coming from a tiny
little town in Australia to living in LA
in I ride my bike along Venice Beach
with the dog and I trained at Gold's I
talked to Arnold Schwarzenegger at the
gym most mornings yeah he's nice freak
now still show up I haven't seen him yet
but apparently he comes Mickey Rourke
was there the other day that gym is so
crazy like when I used to live on on on
marina and forth like riding on the horn
from there a long time ago and I would
go there and there's so much history mmm
you know it's like this is the this is
the birthplace of bodybuilding it's just
packed with like so much so much of that
is just bred into the DNA of that place
and yeah there's Arnold like these
people come in but there's also this
weird thing where you know it's like the
same people every day clock in at like
9:00 in the morning and they clock out
at 5:00 like they're there all day yeah
and it's this weird like mishmash
like porn set meats yeah yeah yeah I've
got this buddy down there who used to be
a celebrity bodyguard a tall tall black
guy I think he's like 65 70 and he had a
stroke and he can barely move one side
of his body and he's still there every
day he can barely move between the
machines without falling over but is
there working out there's as young as
all this fat there Skinner there's such
a melting pot of people and it's
inspiring just to be there without all
the celebrities and stuff there's people
just there because they want to work on
their fitness and they want to be strong
and healthy and they want to make their
lives better yeah and you're always
posting those Instagram videos yeah well
they're all film by Arnold's training
partner he want to follow me around and
and make a mini docker out of my
training so and my friend Mike Ryan
who's a trainer there he's always on my
ass about my he's like oh you know how
the the shark stuff is good but have you
noticed how all your views peak when you
do some workout stuff so I'm like
alright I'll test this out and he was
right yeah I got a lot of views on the
workout stuff and people write to me
asking questions about my prosthetic and
my weightlifting arm and how I use my
leg to train and do squats and stuff
have you ever gone in and worked with
veterans that are kind of in the early
phases of dealing with what you've
you've been dealing yeah back in
Australia I did I went to work with the
soldier recovery center in Brisbane I
was actually dating a navy nurse a few
years back now down in San Diego as she
worked at one of the hospitals down
there and I used to go in and chat to
some of the wounded guys still in
hospitals still in the hospital beds but
not not lately I don't like to force
myself on groups or all people because I
know that there's a lot of people that
want to get involved and always
bothering you know the veteran services
about and I don't like to be like that
if people asked me to go and help I
would do it no problem at all but I'm
not good at asking hey do you want me a
little or pull together they haven't
asked you like I was thinking like
you know there's so many veterans in the
US that are dealing well there's so many
veterans in the u.s. that have overcome
so much now people like marcus luttrell
right and Noah Galloway that there's a
huge group of these people that are
doing just incredible things for their
veteran community and their injured
veterans as well so I think they
probably have their coffers full but
that's not so I would never turn them
down right so you're in this incredible
situation you get to speak to all these
groups and travel all over the world
like what was the impetus to come to the
United States like how did that all come
about I was doing lots of speaking in
Australia and Discovery Channel asked me
for an interview on you and I saw yeah
it's just another interview whatever by
that stage I was quite comfortable in
front of the camera it wasn't a big deal
and they liked it and they liked it so
much they they flew me out to LA to go
on the late-night talkin show during
Shark Week called shark after dark and I
guess they that with me and Mark Cuban
or on the couch together and I guess
they liked that because they gave me a
co-hosting job the next year with this
this insane cameraman called Andy
Casagrande II this guy the things he
does man the things he's we've done
together now I saw my first great white
shark with him I did my first cage
diving with great white sharks with him
in the same shown the same two weeks of
filming they like that's so much they
gave me another one and another one to
the point where I was out here having
some meetings a couple of years ago
about TV shows and my managers said
everyone out here loves you everyone
knows who you are but you're not here
you need to be here if you want this to
grow and so I thought all right now I
went home and I thought about it and I
broke up with my girlfriend and decided
to move to America she was holding me
back anyway
so romantic yeah well you know she
didn't she didn't want to move to mesh
so many things she didn't want to do and
I just wanted to continue to grow as a
person and with a career and so I
decided
just gonna move to America and then a
month after I made that decision I was
still in Australia I got an offer by
NatGeo wild to have my own show and I
just thought holy [ __ ] this is how is
this happening it just keeps getting
better and better and so we talked to
discovery because I was doing some shows
with them and they said no you can't go
work with our competitor so I decided
well do I want my own show why do I want
to stay with my loyalty's to discovery
and stay on Shark Week and I saw you
know I I talked to everyone who got
everyone's opinion and I decided to stay
with discovery and they gave me three
shows a year for two years a working
visa in America development money for my
own show and so I just I moved to
America and I Airbnb
but weensy Nina and America for 18
months and finally got a place three
months ago and now I'm just waiting for
a green light for one of my shows to get
cleared I'm working on another show with
one of your friends about it and I can't
talk about it yet but is um
what an amazing dude if we can pull this
off it would be it would be not just
good for me in him but the main focus is
it'll be good for a small subsection of
the community which is the best part and
now it's just getting bigger and bigger
I just got the sign to one of the
biggest speaking bureaus you know in the
world so I'm out here for the long term
and I love this place Americans are so
sweet they're so welcoming I just had
two days ago I was having lunch with my
girlfriend and a couple secretly paid
for my lunch Wow
that doesn't happen in Australia yeah I
think I've been thanked for my service
three times there and it's not that you
expect it it's not even that you wanted
it's just that it's very sweet for
people to say it still and so I still
appreciate that because we've never had
it before right and you're part of this
Shark Week ecosystem which is just
massive yeah that's like a cultural
phenomenon here and it's such a big deal
but I want to explore the evolution of
you being someone who is victimized by a
shark to being somebody who you know
basically now advocates for shark
reservation and the you know the
ecological implications of you know our
relationship as human beings to sharks
well it's the right thing to do and ever
since I joined the military my focus has
been more on serving and doing the right
thing and you know I have been trained
as a protector so I see now that I'm not
a soldier anymore that's not my job but
my job is to protect and to serve and I
see a lot of wrongs being done against
our planet against the environment
against the oceans and especially
against sharks and over the years out of
necessity I had to learn a lot about
that because every time there was a
shark attack in Australia guess who the
the media tells so you are yeah and
you're the guy who's typing you know
[ __ ] shark yeah one theater or
whatever you know like from the hospital
bed and now you're like the spokesperson
for shark exactly and so everyone was
asking me how I got into sharks and I
was like is that a necessity I have to
how did you get into shark you didn't
have a choice you got on to me yeah but
I didn't want to get on TV and sound
like a dumbass and so I started to do my
research and I started to talk to the
conservation groups and learn from them
Sea Shepherd and a bunch of others that
are out there sharks for kids out of the
Bahamas is an amazing one for kids and
so I learned and I learn and as we know
knowledge dispels fear so break down the
situation with respect to shark
preservation like how do we treat sharks
what's the problem you know what are we
doing wrong you know for somebody who
has no context for this other than like
I'm scared of sharks or I know that
sharks are threatened and certain people
eat sharks or whatever like what's
actually going on there's a lot of
smaller satellite problems involved with
sharks such as people actually fishing
for them for sport fishing them to eight
there's the drum lines and the trial
just kills buttons that's the big one
this is the commercial fishing is the
major contributor legal and illegal so
Sea Shepherd I think last year found a a
Chinese trawler with 1,500 tons of shark
fins on board just the fins just the
fins just the fence so they were
catching all these sharks slicing the
fins off then throwing the carcasses
overboard and there's over a hundred
million sharks killed a year in the
ocean that's unbelievable yeah and some
of these sharks they don't reproduce
quickly some of the ones that they fish
for actually take 35 years to fully
mature before they can have pups so the
birth rate is so slow and the kill rate
is so high 90% of all the oceans large
fish have been wiped out and so explain
how it works with commercial fishing
though they drape these gigantic nets as
there's two ways that they do it the way
you're talking about where they yeah
they like football-field-sized Nets they
just drag them through the ocean floor
picking up everything just totally
destroying coral reefs and habitats for
fish catching whales dolphins sharks
seals everything indiscriminately and
it's all dead and anything that they
don't want so they'll have a quite a
certain amount of fish that they've been
asked to catch like they're trying to
catch tuna exactly and if that if
they've got you know ten tons of tuna
and 20 tons of everything else they'll
just throw the rest of that away a lot
of the time until they can get more tuna
it's all dead so it's just waste they
call it literally call it waste and then
they've got the monofilament nets as
well where they will lay them on the
bottom of the ocean maybe two kilometers
at a time there's probably about 200
kilometers worth of these monofilament
nets surrounding Australia everyday and
they stand about 6 meters high and they
catch everything that swims into them
indiscriminately and kill it and then
they did the same thing so it's the
commercial fishing so that's why Richard
operon Lander calls fishing by its
definition as overfishing yeah
there is no no sustainable fishing is a
myth you cannot sustainably fish and
people think well I'm just kidding
I'm gonna I'm gonna eat these farmed
salmon holy [ __ ] you know bear they are
for you
there they're full of bacteria diseases
they're full of antibiotics to get them
out of the diseases the the salmon
actually have to be fed died pellets so
they have that pink color because
they're like dirty muddy brown if they
don't because they're not eating their
natural food eating a lot of eating pig
[ __ ] out of China and now they're gonna
be genetically modified mm-hmm yeah yeah
that's safe so explain the role of the
shark as the apex predator in the ocean
and why why the shark is so important to
maintaining a proper ecosystem they keep
the balance and the easiest way I've
found to explain this to people who
don't quite understand and that was me
for a long time so I know what you're
getting at saying apex predator and they
keep the balance and they're good for
the ecosystem it's a lot of words that
don't really mean a lot to most people
so I'll give you an example um there's a
lot of them and there was a town in
America I come and what it was and they
fished all of the sharks yeah because
they were eating the food that they
wanted to catch the fisherman sorry so
they're fished all of the sharks out
there was no sharks to eat the Rays the
Rays decimated the mollusk population
and destroyed the mussel and scallop
industry so all of those people were all
out of work all lost their jobs all
their boats were wasted lost their homes
because they couldn't pay their
mortgages because they killed the show
and they think at the time they're doing
the right thing in the best interest of
enhancing their ability to you know
increase their yields he's all right
it's that classic human hubris of
thinking like oh you know I we just take
care of this one thing and we'll solve
the problems without appreciating the
cascading effect of those kinds of
disease
comes back it always comes back on to us
in an untold effect that's that's the
thing that's why every time we mess with
nature wood we're disrupting it all and
so what's going on like in Australia
with the Great Barrier Reef and the this
sort of line I want to slam my head on
the table I mean it's insane you know
it's reaching a tipping point if it
hasn't already passed it these mining
and oil companies as well keep trying to
put a mining route directly through the
Great Barrier Reef this is the only
thing that would even be considered they
want to put an oil rig in the greatest
giant bite which is the big bite looking
thing at the bottom of Australia it is a
massive whale sanctuary there is so much
life out there and I just want to put
this big old rig out there and do blast
testing and destroy the sonars of the
whales and the Dolphins and everything
living out there so all of the citizens
are having to fight this because the
government is just yeah let's make money
they've slashed
the country's marine parks by 50% the
the biggest cut of marine park
protecting marine parks ever that's
happened under our new prime minister
and they're putting out nets and drum
lines to pretend that they're protecting
the swimmers yeah it's amazing you know
it's interesting in the context of diet
when people say well you know I'm pretty
much like on your page rich but you know
I like fish or whatever and fish seems
harmless in the context of thinking of
sentient beings because you can see like
you see yeah or yeah it's just like oh
well you know our one thing pigs are one
thing but like fish is in a different
category but when you fully appreciate
the impact of commercial fishing and
what it's doing to our planet it's just
it's indefensible
yeah and it's wrong as well like the
science has shown that fish have
complicated social groups they have a
centralized nervous system they have
memories there there are a lot more than
we thought they were than the dumb
goldfish memory thing they feel pain and
talking to we're talking about you
really got the chance to talk to you
earlier but I'm talking about you too
John Joseph and another friend of mine
Ian Norrington who's a Brit in Australia
and The Bodyguard guy that John
initially like Wow
he was the connect between you two guys
he was yeah he reached out to me in the
early day saying hey read it all about
you you have quite an impact on the
community you could make it even more
drastic if you thought about going
plant-based and the proceed had already
been planted by a guy called Damien
manda yeah yeah I don't know personally
but I know his story is incredible yeah
he's an amazing man and him and I worked
in the same Navy Department the
clearance divers and I went out there to
Africa to film a documentary for Nat Geo
and I embedded with his anti poaching
unit we went out hunting poachers and I
did the the shooting training unarmed
combat and all that stuff and his meals
were always separate from the Rangers I
what are you eating - means like our I'm
I'm a vegan I was like what's that and
he said I don't need anything that's
from an animal okay why do you do that
for he said well because I felt like a
hypocrite now I was out here protecting
the animals and eating the animals and
me being the rational guy that I am I'm
like err okay that makes sense
totally how are you still so huge I know
so explain who Damien Mandor is for
people that first of all Damien did an
incredible TED talk everybody should
watch I'll put it in the show notes but
I mean this guy is a [ __ ] bad uh-huh
he's a monster and so he was a navy
clearance diver like me he went over and
joined that special forces group that I
told you about the tactical assault
group then when he got bored with the
military he became a private military
contractor out in Iraq and he did
probably 12 13 tours of that place and
then just got sick of the death and the
poverty and the anger and the hate and
he went on Safari looking for a new
cause and on safari in Africa they came
across a rhino with its face hacked off
and he just thought okay this is my call
this is why I came here I was meant to
be here to see this to help make this
stop so against every known possibility
he this giant white man from Australia
went to Africa and managed to get
together this group of people and
convinced them to be Rangers instead of
poaching the animals and it's turned
into this a beast of its own right our
way has just started the can never
pronounce at the ashik of Inga this
group of women the first women
anti-poaching Rangers ever and they out
there hunting the poachers protecting
the animals selflessly you know he sold
all of his homes in Australia to get the
money to put this together he lives very
not poorly what's what I'm looking for
minimally minimally with him and his
wife and his child and when I lived at
their house and it was kind of perfect
at the end of the day we sat back in his
hammock and had a beer and listen to the
hippos sing a hundred metres away in the
creek near his house and listened to the
crocodiles and it was one of the times I
I actually did feel a little bit
threatened in my life because it was
nighttime and I needed to go to the
toilet but the toilet was on the other
side of this dark patch away from the
house and I was literally thinking
everything he wants to eat me I'm not
sure I need to go to the toilet that bad
but what he did really was take this
special forces sensibility and apply
that to a world where he could make a
difference that has traditionally you
know you know people of his mindset
they've been like you know kind of the
tree huggers right you know you know
sort of very you know love exactly and
he comes in with all his training and
his you know ability to like make [ __ ]
happen in a very real way he basically
created a paramilitary group out of
these range yes like the they're not
[ __ ] around nope they're legally
allowed to shoot poachers on-site yeah
it's amazing I didn't know that you I
didn't know that you knew him yeah yeah
we've spent a bit of time together he's
a good man
yeah and I think he you know because of
who he is in his background he you know
he's a powerful figure because I think
he's somebody that like a dude you know
like a like a Type A personality gun can
look to and realize like oh you know
being plant-based like being
quote-unquote like compassionate can
take the form of somebody like that that
you know like an average guy can look to
a guy like that and say you know I want
to be like that guy and I relate to that
person yeah I take great pride when
people see me working out in the gym and
I'm doing chin-ups with 70 pound
dumbbell around my waist this morning I
was doing 120 pound dumbbell presses and
they come they always come over for a
chat because you rarely see a half robot
dude lifting weights oh and it's gold so
everyone talks to each other and they'll
all come over and have a chat and
they're like ah you know how are you so
fitting you ripped and blah blah and I
say well it actually started and became
more prevalent when I went vegan a year
and a half ago and that mind what
steroids you're on where I'm like
broccoli yeah this is a steroid called
spinach so it's been a year and a half
yeah and so it was Damien and John and
and in Ian's were the main influences
all play that pot yeah and it just kept
I tried it once and I failed dismally
because I went in unprepared and then I
gave it another guy a few months later
and I went because I was the sort of guy
that I had to eat all the chickens in
the world I had to get all that protein
in me to get the muscles and I know they
never delivered I never had big muscles
I just couldn't put weight on and didn't
didn't work and so I thought okay well
I'll cancel out red meat I did that
pretty easily cancel out white mate did
that pretty easily because I still had
my beloved fish I love seafood I grew up
spearfishing with my grandfather and
eating stingray and all that so that was
the big one at that in eggs I was
lactose intolerant when I was 15 so
dairy wasn't a problem stole money from
the poor box at church and so God's
moded me because I bought chocolate with
his God money so I lactose-intolerant
since I was a teenager
so eggs and seafood and I got rid of the
seafood but it was the eggs it was like
okay this is my last this is my final
source of protein I must protect it and
then I learnt so much about all the
other sources of protein and now eggs
literally grossed me out and what is
that what is the impact that on your
training and recovery what recovery I
don't need any recovery I train every
day in some form or fashion I haven't
had a serious injury in since I started
in over a year and a half it was almost
like it just happened instantly I'm the
modern day meal that we most people have
is so much now a huge chunk of meat
that's sort of how we we value our meal
okay my meals big enough because I have
this huge chunk of meat in it and then a
little bit of veggies or it's like pasta
with meat all through it and no veggies
at all and now that I don't have that
distraction of the animal products I'm
so much healthy I have so many more
nutrients because I'm eating all of
these vegetables that I never ate before
like who knew spaghetti squash was
incredible and I make that stuff all the
time
I make tofu scramble it looks exactly
like eggs but tastes better when you add
all the veggies and hot sauce and it's
just I by no means starving I'm by no
means grossed out by the food I eat I
make gourmet meals my girlfriend is not
a vegan at all but I cook most of the
time and she's at my house all the time
so she's eating vegan yeah basically
yeah my breakfast every day I actually
look forward to going home after the gym
because I make this bowl I call magic
oats I discovered probably the best
vegan protein on the planet it's better
than any whey protein I've ever had by a
company called high-performance
nutrition
I'm not sponsored by them or anything
but um it's banana maple french toast
flavor mmm and my smoothie bowls are
probably 80% broccoli and spinach and
you can put just one scoop of this stuff
in and it tastes like
Gold yeah I get some some pb2 and some
chia seeds it's a buckwheat and just
combine it all together big scoop of
almond butter and it makes me happy
every time I eat it yeah so when you're
at the gym and and you tell these guys
while I went vegan or and then and then
they ask you where you get your protein
or like the conversation I didn't really
think that it was gonna happen as much
as everyone makes fun of it about
happening you know what I mean like
everyone's like Oh Wade you get your
protein and you see the means all the
time on Instagram I way to get protein I
was like oh that's just whatever I don't
really say that all the time here they
do its in what the health actually and
the doctor says I've never in my whole
career had someone come in dying of a
lack of protein or a protein deficiency
yeah I think that's Garth Ennis yeah
yeah so I get it in food like the same
place the cows and the gorillas and you
get yours from I just don't get it from
meat because it's not good for you it's
interesting that rule that your life
keeps getting better as you are removing
things from your life now you're
removing animal products it just keeps
getting better yeah do you live your own
kind of version of minimalism it's a
different guy yeah that's just gonna be
made the dog soon yeah shed the
girlfriend shed the meat products gained
America and I've you know I'm strong and
I feel good not just in body but I feel
good in my soul I live a whole life
where nothing has to die for me to live
and simply because it's unnecessary
it doesn't have them and I and I would
assume that most of your listeners are
probably vegans vegan is not necessarily
know I mean this show you know look I
have lots of people on that are
plant-based but I want other people on
too I mean there's a lot of vegan
plant-based people that listen but I
wouldn't categorize it as a vegan hot
cat like there's all kinds of people
that yes I I just got to a point where I
realized a lot of these
as I did because I was misinformed or I
felt like I had to because I was a man
and I'm soldier and I had to keep up
that illusion I'm so comfortable in Who
I am now I don't need to prove myself
anymore I served my country in two
different branches of the service I
survived a shark attack I go and do
volunteer work and charity work I can
wear a pink shirt if I want and I can
eat vegetables and as long as I'm doing
good for people and I'm not being a dick
and I'm healthy then I'm happy you know
I'm really in a good place and it's a
lot to do with not having death in my
life it's pretty powerful to hear that
coming from a guy like you you know
someone like me long-distance runner or
whatever you know it's a very different
animal from you know a military guy you
know a kind of guy who looks like you
and has done the things that that you
have done and I think it speaks to a
larger conversation about how we define
masculinity and and what it means to be
a man and it calls into question a lot
of these paradigms that we've set up
about what that looks like you know if
you're a man then you need to eat this
way and behave in a certain way and in
truth I think it beckons or it or calls
for really considering the truth of what
it means to be masculine which is to be
a protector exactly yeah to know when to
exert your strength and to know when to
show compassion see it a few I have to
eat these animals why would you do that
and when you realize by removing them
from your plate that you actually feel
better and perform better it's like a
light switch goes on and then you can
become that ambassador that protector
that that spokesperson for you know a
kinder more compassionate world and do
it in the frame in the body of you know
this this very kind of you know
typically masculine persona yeah it's
the big bad man thing to go on a dia
matin ribs and baby
blablabla and I've had a couple my
friends give the vegan plant-based
lifestyle a crack and my mum for one and
she was looking after my dog when I
first moved out here and she she called
me one day she said look I don't think I
can do this much longer you know he's
too big he's a great day in Cross and I
just you know my hips hurt my rheumatoid
arthritis is really bad I get up in the
middle of the night and I nearly fall
over all the time I'm gonna have to get
a cane and I just thought okay this is
it I've tried I've tried to talk to her
about it so many times and she's just so
stuck in her ways and so it might it
might sound gross but I I went and
booked her in for three colonics to
flush out start flushing out the toxins
I banned her from wine and coffee and I
gave this huge list of things that she
shouldn't be having and I gave her a
whole list of foods that she can use to
cook with and how much water she needs
to drink and within four days I'm not
even joking within four days she calls
me back and she says Paul I got up in
the middle of the night last night and I
did I just walked to the toilet I didn't
feel bad I didn't feel dizzy my hips
weren't hurting I actually this morning
went out walking with the girls again
something I haven't been able to do in
months that's crazy
it's amazing the difference that it can
have on your health and well-being I'm
41 now I don't feel like it I feel
stronger and better than I've ever felt
in my life
yeah and it's just not part of the
conversation when you go to the doctor
no the two weeks with the nutrition Col
stay how your hips are yeah well you you
need to take this and you're gonna need
to take that you're gonna have to start
slowing things down and that's I mean
that dramatic of a difference in such a
short period of time I mean even drugs
can't do that no yeah that's incredible
yeah it's old me well let's talk a
little bit about this you know this
evolution from being attacked by a shark
to being you know somebody who like how
long did it take before you got back in
the water to go be with sharks again and
what was that like
oh man that happened quick because 60
minutes came to the hospital before I
was even at home and I wanted to do a
story and say
I they convinced me to go diving in an
aquarium with some grey nurse sharks and
while I knew nurse sharks I think you
guys call them sand Tigers while I knew
enough about sharks to know that they
weren't gonna harm me they still look
scary you know they got all the teeth
hanging out of their face and so I
didn't feel very comfortable looking at
that so much I looked at the tail but I
did that very quickly and then I didn't
do it again for quite some time any
progression from there I did that same
dive a few times for charity events and
things like that but by then you know
they didn't even feel like sharks they
were just like swimming puppy dogs and
then 16 minutes came back around again
and they said look it's amazing what
you've done getting back to work we want
to do it you know where's Paul now and
they wanted me to go to Fiji and go
diving with bull sharks and like we want
you to face the animal that you know
60-minute cycle of the big deep for its
face the animal that changed his life
forever it'll be great for reading yeah
yeah and so I'm like all I'm thinking is
they're gonna pay for me to go to Fiji
yeah they'll probably pay for my
margaritas to you all right yeah I'll
come to Fiji so when I shot that and to
be honest and not one point did I feel
threatened I didn't feel like the Sharks
were after me I got to see them in just
a natural light there was I think six
different species of sharks there
billions of fish the only thing I got
bitten by was an eel mmm no someone once
told me if you put something bigger than
its mouth in front of it it won't bite
you so this eel came out I was like I
wanted to get close to it I put my fist
up to it which was bigger than its head
and a little bastard bit me on the
knuckle it finally let go and I started
pumping my fist and all this green stuff
came out of my hand I thought oh my god
what does it injected me with and then I
realized I was a hundred and ten feet
down and there's no red at that depth
that was just my blood but the shark's
eye it was eye-opening at the end of
that dive I got to hand feed a bull
shark and it wasn't trying to eat me it
wasn't trying to kill
it wasn't a vicious lurking monster
waiting to do faces you're just out
knock I just no cages no just out there
yeah and no PTSD about doing it no yeah
I sometimes wonder if I'm a little bit
broken shouldn't I by all accounts have
something wrong with me I don't know
it's funny I had I had Alex Honnold in
here yesterday
you know world's greatest free soloist
climber that guy climbed El Capitan
without ropes like he's done just the
most unbelievable things and he had you
know everyone asked him like about his
relationship with fear and his
relationship with death and I think
there's some overlap between how he
perceives it and and perhaps how you
perceive it coming from different
experiences and what was interesting is
that he was saying look you know what I
do like if you know he's on those rock
fit you you lose your grip like you're
dead like there's no I mean there's no
if ands or buts about it it's not like
oh you're putting yourself at risk it's
a very binary thing right and so that
makes him have to be very present with
the reality of death so he lives with a
sensibility about death that most people
just compartmentalize or put in their
you know in their unconscious mind like
we walk around thinking we're not going
to die or yeah we kind of academically
know everybody's going to die but but
you know maybe it's not gonna happen to
me you know that kind of thing yeah and
as somebody who survived what you've
survived you had a you know a brush with
death in in you know the most palpable
way possible and so I would imagine your
relationship with death and your
appreciation for life is different than
most human beings but the other thing
about Alex was that like how can this
guy do this stuff and maintain hit
maintain his focus and concentration and
and and presence when he's in this
situation of being on these were these
rock climbing walls so they did an MRI
on his brain to see if there's like
something wrong with it they're like
this guy's amygdala must not fire which
I you know I guess is responsible for
the fear impulse all right and they
found out he's like no I actually have
an amygdala you know but it but it
doesn't it doesn't like you know
function in the way that most human
beings do so
there's something there amuse you yeah
you're an MRI of your brain well I think
it has to do with your experience like
Oh totally you I mean after you've
survived what you survived for I would
imagine your relationship with life and
death is is different like what you know
what does fear look like for you well I
I here already accepted death when I was
under the water for those 10 seconds
drowning in total agony I came to a
realization that I was going to die my
brain was telling me okay you're gonna
die right now you're not going home
today this is it and so I accepted it
already and I just thought everything
sped up in my brain and I was thinking a
million miles a minute and I just
thought well I've lived 10 lives in
these 31 years if it's my time to die
then I'm okay with that
and so I let go and a Carm came over me
and then the shock removed my hand
removed from my hamstring and because of
my wetsuit I was positively buoyant and
I popped to the surface and I looked
around and the the tail of the shark
splash water in my face and I saw my
safety boat and I thought oh [ __ ] I'm
not dead I better get out of here so I
started to swim me back to the boat and
so I I already accepted death and I
realized that it's not it's nothing to
be afraid of yeah so how does that color
your day-to-day life well I I don't have
to hold on to the mortal coil like
everyone else does because I know that
death is not scary you know what's scary
not living not doing everything that you
possibly can to live the best life you
have because trust me when you come to
the end of your days the only thing
you're gonna have is your regrets and if
you don't have any of those so sweet
home run you've got nothing to worry
about so then you're feeding bull sharks
by your hands yep and now you know they
had a shock wake last year at the start
of 2017 I was diving with great white
sharks without a cage in the middle and
nowhere [ __ ] Western Australia like a
handful of people maybe have done it
that's insane and yeah it's it's
incredible to be 110 feet down with
three massive male great white sharks
swimming around you and all you have is
a GoPro on a stick how do you I mean
what is the
you know the situation in which a great
white or bull shark is going to be
provoked to attack you versus being you
know simpatico with them in the water
look the first thing is they're a wild
animal you never going to be able to
predict what they do 100% of the time
you kind of have to just rely on your
experiences and rely on your knowledge
and I've learned from the best
that the guy Annie Kuster grandi I've
done a bunch of shows with him now and I
always keep my mouth shut and my ears
open when I'm dealing with people like
that I have a lot of trust with him I
did that dive with him and so I've
learned how to read the Sharks how to
read their posture and really the
greatest thing the greatest piece of
advice that anyone ever gave me was
don't act like food they won't treat you
like food even how what is it what does
that mean might never retreat always
keep your eyes on them sharks and
actually see looking at them a lot of
the times tiger sharks great white
sharks they'll try and ambush you from
behind as soon as you turn around they
actually register that you're looking at
them and they swim in the other
direction
yeah it's mind blowing as funny to see
because they come out of the murk at you
and it's literally like you're watching
a horror movie at this gigantic great
white shark swimming directly at your
face and you want to turn and you want
to swim as fast as you can back to that
cage but you can't because it'll eat
it'll chase you down and I'll eat you
and you've been in that situation yeah
coming at you and you have to maintain
your composure to such an extent they
like staring down the bull Wow
yeah it was crazy and it did it it swam
up to me and I saw the nose and I saw
the eyes and the teeth and then the fins
out the side and was like a mini bus
with teeth and fins coming at me and I
just had to stay there even though I was
very very nervous that it was gonna bite
my head off
and it just went around me mm-hmm
and that was it and then eventually we
swam back to the cage and I came to the
surface and I was fine and I got to see
these remarkable animals without the
bars in the way one on one not acting
like food
not as prey so if I find myself out in
the ocean and I'm confronted with a
shark
stare them in the face yeah just keep
your eyes on it try and watch it at all
times I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to handle that well it's your other
option do you go out in and out here and
like Malibu or Westside and go in the
ocean no I haven't had any need to
mm-hmm I'm I used to like surfing but
I'm just not very good at it on this
prosthetic leg I've seen this kid as
this he's created this really great
surfing prosthetic I want to get one of
those because it looks much easier to
stand on because I do like surfing I'm
just really terrible at it when I can't
feel my foot or my knee but um I he led
out he has a motorized surfboard or
something I want to get one of those I
don't know I have seen those like
hydrofoil surfboards that are like
boosted board skateboards but yeah
surfboards and they rot right they serve
rise up with a hydrofoil and they're
like electric motorized yeah and people
ride around on that I love one of those
so I've surfed a 10 foot wave but I got
towed into it on the back of a jetski
the only problem I don't have surely all
right here in Australia I don't have
anyone to tie me around into Jessica's
just to watch me surf unfortunately so
when you go and you give these talks
what is the you know what's the message
that you're trying to leave people with
it really depends on what the client
asks me to talk about because I talk to
everyone from primary school kids six
seven eight years old surprisingly
enough all the way through high school
all the way through college
all through military groups or big
business now I've got IBM coming up
Microsoft big investment corporations
twelve bankers - twelve CEOs in a room -
and just me right I'll talk about
whatever they need to focus on so
there's a lot of common themes as
embracing change because a lot of them
go through takeovers and they're getting
melded together with other companies and
it's a change of culture and it's a
change of personnel and everyone always
fights against change because it makes
them uncomfortable and that
wanna do something different when
they're comfortable doing it this way so
talking to them about embracing change
and the opportunity that comes out of
changing with the situation overcoming
adversity obviously working that the
team Network being able to focus on
looking after each other
and doing a better job that way so it's
not just helping people on a personal
level it helps people throughout the
whole process of living being happy the
secrets of being happy so you wouldn't
you would probably believe I would
normally say you wouldn't believe you
would probably believe how many unhappy
people there are there's no question
about it and I've made them every time I
finish my presentation sometimes they
break down in my arms just because
they're so grateful because you've given
them a little nugget to make them
believe that they can still be happy and
what is the message that you're
delivering unhappiness
well that's it's all about what you
value and what is going to improve your
life the they have to be on common
ground what we were talking about
earlier doing things for other people
I've never had a greater sense of
happiness than doing things for other
people that can't pay me back it's
mostly weaved throughout the story the
things that have really broken my heart
and the things that have made me elated
and the value that I found in things
that I really didn't think I would and
that giving with no expectation of
receiving is a big one even if it's
something as simple as going to the
blood bank it doesn't cost you anything
cost a little bit of time going in throw
some blood down a tube because I went
through 150 donations and I could have
all the doctors in the world I can have
the best surgeons but without that blood
from those 150 amazing people I would
not be here today it doesn't take a
grand gesture it just a pat on the back
a well done a handshake take someone out
for a coffee and be a kind ear if it's
one that maybe doesn't have anyone to
turn to a work because they're not
really well-liked maybe just put up with
it and and go and have a chat with them
and make them happy because you might
change that person's whole day or whole
outlook on life and that only comes back
to you it makes you feel good that's
where happiness is found in service it's
so true and it's it's such
counter-programming
from what we're kind of told growing up
because we're kind of set in motion on
this on this path of like trying to get
as much as we can out of everything and
we approach situations with a
perspective of like how am I gonna gain
from this what's in this for me like how
am I gonna come out of this better than
I was before and that doesn't really
lead to happiness you know it does not
and when you approach a situation and
encounter whatever it may be from a
perspective of how can I give how can I
contribute to this then you're on you're
on a different you know that's that's a
different plane of consciousness and
it's not my default but when I remember
and I practice it's exactly it's a
practice it's a practice it's like it's
not just like oh well that guy just
that's his instinct and that's how he
does it like no you have like what how
do you know if to do that and you get
good at anything how do you learn to
ride a bike or learn to read or play a
sport or do your job you do it over and
over and over until you get really good
at it
it's the same with happiness the same
with gratefulness it's the same with
positivity and motivation you have to
keep practicing it and the more you do
the easier it gets
mm-hmm improvise adapt overcome yeah
that's the best year's trifecta I am in
and that's what they drill down on you
in in the military right with that Kant
did that come from experience it did
it's it wasn't really drilled into me
like it is I think it's one of the
matches for the Marine Corps out here I
think I heard it maybe once or twice way
back in basic training but it had an
impact on my brain like it was seared
into my brain and I had no idea why and
then I got into the gym one day after
hospital and I had one hand and one leg
and that'll really throw out your
benchpress and squats and so
all of a sudden that improvise adapt and
overcome clicked in and I'm like okay
alright I might not be able to do
push-ups I can't wait there on the end
of my arm I'll improvise and I pulled a
bench over and I put my right elbow on
the bench and my right hand left hand on
the floor and I did push-ups like that
and I thought well I can't do dumbbell
curls and I thought well I'll adapt you
know in the next step I'll adapt and I
got online and I found the lifting hooks
that they use for heavy deadlifts where
you you loop it around your wrist and
then you use the hook to put under the
bar and you can lift heavier without
gripping it and I got that thing and I
slipped the material loop over my
forearm and I rested I let it hang down
and I put a dumbbell in it and I can do
70 pound curls with that thing now I
flick it up into the hooks and I can do
flies with it you don't have two legs
for squats does that mean you skip leg
day mmm you never skip leg day you do
pistol squats you do them on the smith
machine where it does the balance for
you there's there's always a way with
the right tools and sometimes the right
tool is just the right mindset that's an
example on a very micro level but on a
macro level like this these three ideas
are really the arc of your life right
are using everyday you you had to
improvise you had to adapt and you
ultimately had to overcome in order to
be sitting here and getting to do what
you get to do mm-hmm and now I'm just
enjoying the ride
no that's it's all gonna come back you
know I use those every day there's
always trials we all have our stories
you know that's one of the big things I
I do try and share everyone says ah Paul
you know you were a late
military-trained and you can do this and
you can do that and I was like no I'm
like I was a failure first and I still
struggle with a lot of stuff and I drop
mugs in the kitchen and I smash them
because I'm clumsy and I'm just a person
just like all of you I make the same
mistakes but I don't give up because I
know that there's always going to be a
better moment there's always going to be
a better day I find joy
everything that I do in everything that
I share with people and there's just no
reason to quit we have this overwhelming
suicide and depression problem going on
at the moment it's all around the world
it's it's huge in Australia it's huge
here and it's just really sad to say
especially amongst the our veteran
community of people just not feeling
like they can deal with it anymore that
maybe there's nowhere to turn to bidets
always somewhere to turn to and there's
always a better date it's interesting
that that sometimes these calamities you
know like you experienced are are really
the catalyst to to growth and being able
to embrace life and the way that in the
way that you have because they force you
to your needs and you have to confront
yourself in a very profound way and you
know I know that's why you look back on
this experience and like you know you've
you value the life that you have right
now most people are not going to get
attacked by a shark or bottomed out on
drugs and alcohol or have a near-death
experience they're just living their
lives in a kind of monochrome you know
no not this way where they feel like
they're doing everything right like I
made the right decision and I got the
safe job and I'm doing all these things
and I'm super depressed and I'm on these
medications and I'm overweight and I
feel like [ __ ] and I can't see my way
out of this because it's a situation
that's not so bad that you're gonna just
walk out of it mmm it's like a low
agreeable in there Azeri yeah it's a
low-grade discontent that's the wood
there's a world right live like that
stop stop eating [ __ ] work on your
fitness go have a frickin adventure
there's a big bad world out there with
so much adventure and fun to be had go
and see some [ __ ] that you've never seen
before which is probably most of the
world if you're comfortable comfortable
in your misery already in life just get
uncomfortable it's it's the the best
thing ever and that's a muscle just like
anything else like the other things we
were talking about
like that can start with a very small
thing oh yeah to exercise that and then
you can turn the volume up on mm-hmm
step by step
yeah it's it's so much easier it's it's
exactly what I did when I left the
hospital I had that huge goal of getting
back to work it didn't just happen that
was impossible don't believe that it
could actually be done a one-legged
one-handed clearance table you can't go
back to work and go diving and I did it
in six months now I did it by small
goals and challenges get up earlier eat
better drink more fluids get off the
drugs exercise more just tiny little
things that built up over time to learn
how to walk go to the gym box jump a
meter high going the ocean swim more it
progresses but the smaller the goals and
challenges you set for yourself the more
they build up the more you turn back and
you look behind yourself and you go holy
[ __ ] look at all of that stuff I've done
okay what's next now I know I can do all
of that what's next let's do something a
little harder a little more fun a little
more challenging and before you know it
those small easily achieved goals have
become an impossible dream yeah it's the
imperceptible actions that you take
anonymously every day with you know
rigorous consistency that change your
reality and people want to pay it's like
they want to they want to you know do
the dramatic thing overnight they want
the hut to hack in the shortcut or
whatever it's like it's not about that
man
it's about it's just like you do that
tiny thing that makes you a little bit
uncomfortable flex that muscle you get a
little history with that you realize
like hey I didn't die like I can do this
now and that's what that I think is the
path that it's the less sexy path it's
not the dramatic path that you're going
to be able to like get a bunch of likes
on Instagram for but that is truly the
method for sustainably changing your
life in a profound way
if Instagram locks is what you're after
then just make a story about all the
little things yeah I was hanging out
with the
yesterday who did the the hundred things
hundred things to make people happy I
think it was and his mission is just to
go out and start helping people in need
and he's made a website and now he
advertises these people who need help
and all these other people are offering
to give them assistance in some form or
fashion as well so they can help out
it's it's just the act of giving an act
of just small stuff and that started
with an idea yeah yeah and in
perceivable little atom hmm
I think that's a good place to end it
dude all right are you uh speaking
publicly anywhere coming up soon if
people want to you know figure you out
and come and see you in person is there
any opportunity to do that or not at
this point now everything that I've got
going on is for private corporations but
I've only just started out here so I
only have a few I've got you know I'm
doing some stuff in Hawaii in Atlanta
and for the entrepreneurs organization
if you're part of that and also for the
Nantucket project if you've got any idea
what that is I do because I went to high
school Tom Scott no idea right Tom is
actually coming over here in a week or
two I haven't seen him in a long time
and I have him do the podcast when I we
were high school classmates yeah he's an
Oscar I watched it I actually have it
pulled up here I was I was watching your
presentation at Nantucket project and
it's it's quite amazing what he's built
with that I did not realize what it was
when I got there it was just another
speaking job for me and I turned up
there and I literally got off the plane
past the summer yep yeah I got off the
plane went straight to the school talked
for 45 minutes to the to the school kids
went from there to the stage went on
stage and did my presentation then I got
off and then I found it was the rest of
them like the President of Mexico the
President of Rwanda the guy who started
TED Talks
captain Paul Watson I'm just thinking
geez I'm glad that I went on first
you know Jennifer gana Mach Shriver and
I'm just thinking oh my god and little
old pulled together yeah it's cool it's
cool what he's built did you meet Neal
Phillips I not sure presented last night
he's a african-american guy who started
a school in Florida for kind of
empowering underprivileged
african-american kids I did meet someone
very similar to that I'm not sure if it
was from Florida they anyway he was
another classmate of mine like Neal and
Tom were like best friends in high
school
I can't collaborate on stuff and I know
Neal presented it and took a project I
don't know if it was last summer but
okay we heard of a guy called um Jason
Flom yes so he was there and I got
talking to him and him and I became
pretty good friends in a very short
amount of time
and the things that he's doing is
amazing yeah it has 43 convicts
remaining falsely accused convicts yeah
he's got a foundation set up for that I
mean yeah that's amazing I follow those
stories all the time and you think your
life's hard try being in jail for 30
years falsely accused so you're doing
more with Nantucket project man yeah I
got a couple of satellite keys coming up
Palm Beach and the Hamptons but it's
only you know this is very early days
for me out here now that I've got the
well the contraction not exactly signed
our publishing I said that but I'm more
than likely gonna be signed with the
American program Bureau and so I'll have
a team of people advertising my services
Sony the CEOs out there and want to who
want to hire Paul to come out and talk
to there oh hell yeah I'm always trying
to get my my passing out numbers oh yeah
cool and and the best way to connect
with you probably Instagram right I Paul
de Gelder Instagram the website Paul de
Gelder comb they're the two best and
most fluid ways and the book and over
fear yeah pick it up right and the
second estate second ones in the editors
now surrounded by monsters what's the
next one gonna be about it's it's a bit
of a follow on with more lessons that
I've learned along the way behind the
scenes on Discovery Channel Shark Week
shoots catching crocodiles and diving
with sharks and stuff cool when is that
coming out what's with the editors now
so if it was up to me it'd be tomorrow
but
hopefully within the next couple of
months mmm nice man all right dude well
you're an inspiration and I can't wait
to see where you take this dude it's
incredible what you're doing and and
yeah you're impacting a lot of lives and
a really profound in positive ways
that's are you for that thank you for
your service all right and come back and
talk to me anytime
yeah I'll hopefully I'll run into you
Malibu again a cool piece
[Music]